We have very big political news to talk about
today.
Ohio has decided to switch to an all by mail
Democratic primary, which will run essentially
from now until April 20th.
And the idea is a good one.
Republican Governor Mike DeWine in Ohio has
been one of the best governors on the Corona
virus response.
But there are major concerns about the specifics
of how Ohio is doing this.
And you'll very clearly understand why when
I give you the details for context.
Earlier this week, Nancy Pelosi said on MSNBC
that in general, because of the virus, we
should be switching to mailing in our ballots.
And I completely agree.
Trump doesn't want this.
We know why Trump doesn't want it.
Trump knows that if more people can vote more
easily in November, it's bad for him.
It's more likely that he does not get a second
presidential term.
And it's good for Democrats.
So there's this battle where Nancy Pelosi
wants to vote by mail.
Donald Trump does not want vote by mail.
Now, you might remember that the Ohio Democratic
primary was scheduled for Tuesday, March 17th.
That was sort of like Super Tuesday three.
We had Super Tuesday on March 3rd, colloquially,
Super Tuesday 2 on March 10th, and then Super
Tuesday three on March 17th.
Ohio postponed because of the virus.
The idea was to reschedule to June 2nd.
The new plan is it will be a mail in primary
in Ohio.
And voters will have until April twenty eighth
to submit their ballots.
Now, in general, this does sound good.
And indeed, Republican Governor Mike DeWine
said he would sign this bill soon and we can
get started on this vote by mail Democratic
primary.
But there are some concerns that voters are
going to end up disenfranchised because the
way that this is likely to work out is the
Ohio secretary of state is going to send out
a postcard to every registered voter and the
postcard will say, hey, we're voting by mail.
You have to request an absentee ballot.
And that is really the source of the problem
here, because even if you are a registered
voter, you won't get a ballot automatically.
You'll get a card that tells you how to ask
for a ballot.
Now, the reason for this and this is true,
that the secretary of state says this and
this is true.
The absentee ballot rules, as many of you
know in many states are you have to request
an absentee ballot.
You can't just send ballots to everybody.
You have to have a process whereby someone
says, I want an absentee ballot and here's
why.
That's true.
But these are special circumstances.
These are unprecedented circumstances.
So what should be done is in the Corona virus
bill that's being passed, which includes that
there's going to be a vote by mail primary.
They should include a provision that changes
the rule.
It suspends the rule and says we're going
to send everybody a ballot instead of a postcard.
In other words, decide as a legislature, this
particular circumstance is so unusual and
so different.
We need to suspend the you must request the
ballot rule because otherwise the timeline
probably won't work.
It's April 2nd today.
That leaves us 26 days for voting.
In those 26 days, the state needs to design,
agree upon a design, print and mail postcards
to every registered voter.
Voters then need to in the midst of everything
everybody's dealing with.
Send that back or rather go through the process
of asking for a ballot, which according to
the secretary of state's web site, you have
to print and sign the ballot request form,
mail it back by snail mail.
Those ballots then need to be sent out.
Feet be filled out.
And again, you have to mail that back.
It's really not reasonable.
And the ACLU and other groups agree this will
disenfranchise people.
So we need to see how they deal with this.
I believe the simplest path is simply suspend
the rule that says you have to request an
absentee ballot.
Say this is such an extenuating circumstance.
We're sending a ballot to everybody.
Now, in terms of the race itself in Ohio,
the latest polling we have out of Ohio is
from mid-March.
Things could have changed since then.
Two polls from mid-March in one of them.
Joe Biden is ahead of Bernie by twenty three
in another mid-March poll.
Joe Biden is ahead of Bernie by 22.
It's been two weeks of virus craziness.
It's conceivable that those numbers may have
changed to some degree.
We don't know.
But that is the latest out of Ohio.
And we will let you know probably by Monday
there if there's no advancement on this by.
One day we know it simply is not going to
work.
Make sure that you sign up for the David Pakman
show newsletter at David Pakman dot com.
Why?
Next Thursday, April 9th, we are doing a one
day membership bomb.
I told you yesterday that in March, because
of the virus, a lot of people are tightening
the belts and we had three hundred and eighty
nine people cancel memberships in March.
That's a record for us.
We want to set records for new members.
Instead, we set a record for canceled memberships.
We are also on YouTube experiencing about
a 35 percent revenue decline, again, because
of what's going on with the virus.
So the idea is Thursday, April 9th, everybody
on our mailing list will get an email with
a special one time coupon code.
We want to have like a big single day membership
drive to be notified about that discount.
Just sign up for my mailing list at David
Pakman dot com.
In the meantime, let me know on Twitter, how
is the isolation going in your city, town,
state, village, country.
Wherever you are.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
this.